plus dur que c'était finalement un
discours de normand c'est à dire
peut-être ben qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non
c'est un discours flou nettement
insuffisant est ce que je remarque c'est
que ce discours flou et insuffisant il
se tient au moment où sa majorité
parlementaire trouve en votant l'impôt
sur la fortune des plus riches la
suppression de l'impôt pour la fortune
des plus riches
plusieurs milliards d'euros mais quand
il vient voir les départements pour le
financement de la solidarité nationale
en faveur de nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles eh bien là c'est toujours pour
plus tard donc c'est un discours
particulièrement décevant pour les
départements est très inquiétant quant à
notre capacité d'agir